[Music]
all right it's time to raise those
rainbow flags pride month is here and
las vegas pride the organization is
ready to celebrate and raise awareness
for our local lgbtq plus community so
vice president jocelyn hatfield is here
to give us the rundown how are you hello
hello hi happy pride i wore my rainbow
for years or at least tie dye i love
that i love your outfit as well you got
the rainbow colored sandals you are
ready to go yes i am how are you feeling
oh wonderful
it's so great to be here thank you for
having me oh of course and when you hear
like shake shack and all these other
organizations coming together to
celebrate with you
what does that make you feel
proud yeah i mean it's just amazing to
have great partners people who are
invested in the lgbtq
community i mean it's just an incredible
feeling and so we're very excited for
pride month yeah we are all celebrating
with you now tell us a little bit about
las vegas pride and the organization
itself you guys have been around for
about 30 years now yeah we've been here
for over 30 years okay so we've been
serving the las vegas community with
the las vegas pride festival annually
and the parade
and we have kind of ongoing programming
throughout the year that just really
celebrates being proud of who you are
absolutely and how are we kicking things
off you're seeing video right now of the
festival and the parade and all of the
party and fun so how are we kicking
things off specifically this year for
2022 well vegas is a little unique right
so a little unique well i mean
really unique right so we celebrate
pride month actually twice our paradigm
festival's in october when it's a little
bit cooler but this year we were really
intentional about putting out some
programming to celebrate the community
so beautiful tonight tonight at resorts
world yes we are kicking things off with
our pride family bingo cool things uh
the door starts at 6 p.m and then the
first ball drops at seven okay we see it
right there on our screen yes yes that's
it and the really great thing about this
event is that it not only benefits las
vegas pride but it also benefits the
lgbtq center of southern nevada oh
beautiful so it's kind of a two-for-one
you can get a lot of bang out of your
buck but i love i love that okay and
besides that besides the kickoff event
you know there's a full rundown there's
a whole list you've got even a mag
special edition of your magazine coming
out to accelerate that so tell us about
the other events we can join that's
right thank you so much so our las vegas
pride magazine is every other month our
pride edition issue dropped in digital
today nice and it'll be hitting the
streets in print in about a week or so
okay and then we have a pride outside
hike which is a free community event
we're at mount charleston this month
that's in the middle of the month we
just have a whole lot of stuff going on
so the best way to get involved with the
things that we have going on is visiting
las vegas pride.org okay to find out
what's shaking but what's shaking and i
know there's a there's an aces event
there's a black girl magic event there's
just something for everybody in pride
month and beyond really you guys are
doing this year round that's right yeah
i'm glad you mentioned the aces because
it's a really big deal for us we are the
non-profit of the night at their pride
game which is on sunday and sunday is
kind of a big day anyway because we have
not one not two but three different
events happening we have the aces event
we're the non-profit the night we're
joining our friends at mgm resorts at
temptation sunday at the luxor
and we also have a queer women's party
at caesars at the link pool um at cesar
so sorry at the link right and um we're
just super stoked to kick things off
right this year that is awesome and just
really quick if someone can't you know
attend one of your events just how can
people celebrate and support you guys
well in any number of ways they can
volunteer for any number of great
organizations including ours
we are volunteering at for the election
coming up with the election department
so visit our website las vegas pride.org
to find out more information about that
and really just be out invisible and
proud
that goes for the community and our
allies definitely thank you so much
jocelyn and happy friday
thank you